[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen Freedom has
different manifestations but the most
important for many is the ability to
work for your benefit for the benefits
of your children and the one of your
country in Ukraine we are fighting for
everything that you have we stand so
that every Ukrainian would enjoy all the
manifestations of Freedom available to a
free person in the Democratic Society we
have achieved significant results we
have United the whole world around our
struggle for Freedom we are liberating
ukrainians territory from the Russian
army we have already started or
renovated everything that was destroyed
by the Russian Terror we are rebuilding
our economy we are giving you and your
companies the opportunity to work
together with us for the benefit of all
us Ukraine is the story of a future
Victory and a chance for you to invest
now in projects worth of hundreds of
billions of dollars to share the victory
with us today we kick start a
large-scale promotion campaign to
attract Investments Advantage Ukraine we
will tell the world why Ukraine is a
place for good Investments and financial
opportunities I invite you to Ukraine
invest in Ukraine this will be your
Victory and a new success story for your
companies slavo grainy start your work